. Let's go next to Patrick from Vernon Hills,
Patrick from Vernon Hills. You're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
I have maybe more of a historical question
for you, but do you have any examples of maybe the
US or other countries that have gone from times of
heavy propaganda or sensational news to
better news systems? And how have nations
done that? Like what regulations or laws or
social movements in particular? I'm thinking
of the yellow journalism in the 20th century
or the Red Scare in the middle of the 21st.
Yeah, I mean, I guess my mind goes to
transitioning from from two thoughts come to mind.
World War two and Cold War, where there was
a lot of propaganda. I mean, I think like,
OK, take Estonia as an example, which I think is
an interesting one, because they're one of the
countries that has best sort of recovered from the
fall of the Soviet Union and exited the Cold War,
very technologically advanced, very open when
it comes to media. I think that the examples
always go along with some change in the type of
government you have. And so I think that that
maybe is a cautionary tale from the standpoint
of to really get away from a media apparatus
and maybe government propaganda apparatus
that that is weaponized disinformation. You
typically need substantive change to who's
in charge and the type of people that are
in charge. But but I think Estonia is sort of an
interesting example in the post Soviet Union era.
Cool, thanks. One more if you're fine with it.
Angang has proposed a few times giving people
money to invest in their local journalism outlets,
so on your tax returns, you get like 100 bucks or
something, and you can only use that to donate
to a person or organization that's registered as
a news organization to help rebuild local news
outlets. What do you think of that proposal?
That's very interesting. I've not heard of
that. I've heard of another idea where you
can designate money for local elected officials
rather than I think when you do your taxes is a
question of like, do you want to put three bucks
towards like the presidential election fund or
something like that? I've never met anybody
who says yes to that. But some people must.
The idea of doing it for four local, I think
it's very interesting. I think the devil is
in the details. I'd want to know more about
exactly how it's done, but I like the idea.
Thank you. All right, by the way, I think I like
the idea better of with the politicians, one of
just getting money out of politics and having
public financing of elections rather than giving
people the option to participate in the system.
Let's change the system. But when it comes to when
it comes to media, I think it's more interesting.
Yeah, the freedom dividend, I thought was a genius
idea. I never heard that Xiangyang
and it just really changed. I was so
pessimistic about money in politics until
I heard that I was like a genius, like.
All right, my friend, thank you for the call.
Thank you. All right, take care. OK, very good.